Choice Hotels get you more of what you value. Comfort in. It's calling your name. Save on the stay. Oh, and free waffles are yours to claim. Book direct at storesotails.com. When a new school year begins, students are dealing with classes, sports, and other extracurricular activities. Most students will also face an entirely different set of challenges with peer pressure.
Choice Hotels 让您获得更多您所看重的价值。Comfort Inn 正在呼唤您。住宿即可省钱。哦，还有免费华夫饼等着您。请直接在 storesotails.com 预订。新学年开始时，学生们要应对课程、体育和其他课外活动。大多数学生还将面临来自同伴压力的一系列完全不同的挑战。
Parents may notice a change in how their child dresses or behaves at home. home, how much of this is related to their friend's influence and how should parents address peer pressure with their children? In this podcast, we talk with a psychologist who looks at the science behind peer pressure, both the good and the bad. Brett Lowerson is a professor of psychology at Florida Atlantic University, where his research focuses on how children and teens interact with their peers and parents. Specifically, he studies how these relationships affect their social lives and academics. Dr. Lawerson is a fellow of the American Psychological Association. Welcome. Thanks. It's a pleasure to speak with you. When does peer pressure typically
家长们可能会注意到孩子在穿着或居家行为上的变化。那么，这其中有多少与朋友的影响有关？家长又该如何与孩子谈论同伴压力呢？在本期播客中，我们采访了一位心理学家，他从科学角度审视了同伴压力的利与弊。Brett Laursen 是佛罗里达大西洋大学的心理学教授，他的研究重点是儿童和青少年如何与同伴及父母互动。具体来说，他研究了这些关系如何影响他们的社交生活和学业。Laursen 博士是美国心理学会的会士。欢迎您。谢谢。很高兴能与您交谈。同伴压力通常在什么时候
begin to occur in children's lives? And what impact does it have on child and adolescent development? Before we tackle that question, I think it's important to define peer pressure. If we define peer pressure as essentially influence, then I think we can see that peer pressure begins very early on. But it's not often the way that parents and adults think of it. You have explicit peer pressure and you have implicit peer pressure. So let me give you an example. I know of a young man who just started middle school, and it started it with long hair,
开始出现在孩子的生活中？它对儿童和青少年的发展有什么影响？在解决这个问题之前，我认为定义同伴压力很重要。如果我们把同伴压力本质上定义为一种影响，那么我认为我们可以看出同伴压力很早就开始了。但这通常不是家长和成年人所认为的那样。你有显性的同伴压力，也有隐性的同伴压力。让我举个例子。我认识一个刚上中学的年轻人，他刚开始时留着长发，
and a couple of months into middle school, he got his haircut very short. This could have been because somebody made fun of his long hair, that would be the explicit form of peer pressure. But it could also be very implicit. He could have wanted to fit in. he could have been eager to make new friends. Other kids with short hair,
上了几个月中学后，他把头发剪得很短。这可能是因为有人嘲笑他的长发，这就是显性的同伴压力。但也可能是非常隐性的。他可能只是想融入集体，他可能渴望结交新朋友。其他留短发的孩子，
who didn't want them to be off put by his long hair. He could have thought this is some form of status, people with short hair, could have more status than people with long hair. We don't know in this particular instance, and we often don't really know exactly if it's one or the other, and typically it's probably a combination of things. So when we think about peer pressure,
可能不想因为他的长发而对他产生反感。他可能认为这是一种地位的象征，留短发的人可能比留长发的人地位更高。在这个特定的例子中，我们不得而知，而且我们通常并不真正知道到底是哪一种，通常可能是多种因素的结合。所以当我们想到同伴压力时，
we're really talking about influence to behave, differently. That's exerted by peers. So when does it begin? It begins as soon as children start to pay attention to what other children think about them. So we can see peer influence in the very early grade school years. We see it over behavior problems where one set of peers will influence another to act badly. We also see it over academic achievement where friends do better when they're paired with other kids who are doing better in school. And we've seen this as early as first grade. Our data in both Finland and in the U.S.
我们实际上是在谈论同伴施加的、改变行为的影响。那么它从什么时候开始呢？当孩子们开始关注其他孩子对他们的看法时，它就开始了。所以我们在小学低年级就能看到同伴的影响。我们看到它在行为问题上的体现，即一群同伴会影响另一群人表现不佳。我们也看到它在学业成绩上的体现，即当孩子们与学校表现更好的孩子结对时，他们的表现也会更好。我们早在一年级就看到了这一点。我们在芬兰和美国的数据
suggest that these influences happen with very young children. Why are some children and teens more susceptible to peer pressure than others? Because you see some kids that generally seem to just do their own thing and not care what other children think of them, but that's not always the case. and why are some of them so more susceptible to that? We're still working to disentangle the notion of susceptibility from the notion of being really influential. So on the one hand, there are some children who are susceptible to influence from anyone,
都表明这些影响发生在非常年幼的孩子身上。为什么有些孩子和青少年比其他人更容易受到同伴压力的影响？因为你会看到有些孩子似乎总是做自己的事，不在乎其他孩子怎么看他们，但情况并非总是如此。为什么他们中的一些人更容易受到影响？我们仍在努力将“易受影响性”的概念与“具有影响力”的概念区分开来。一方面，有些孩子容易受到任何人的影响，
that is to say, that comes down the pike, they're likely to follow. But it's also the case that some people are more influential. And so if you hang around with people who tend to be particularly influential, You will look susceptible, even though you're not particularly susceptible. It just happens to be that you're hanging around with others who are highly influential. So I'll try to address that question, but I want to put that big caveat out there first because if you're hanging around with somebody who's very persuasive and who has a lot of social skills, you may look susceptible.
也就是说，无论谁来，他们都可能跟随。但同样的情况是，有些人更有影响力。所以如果你和那些特别有影响力的人在一起，你看起来就会很容易受影响，即使你本身并不特别容易受影响。这只是因为你和那些极具影响力的人在一起。所以我试着回答这个问题，但我首先想提出这个重要的警告，因为如果你和某个非常有说服力且社交能力很强的人在一起，你可能看起来很容易受影响。
In fact, you're not particularly susceptible to other people. It just has to do with those that you spend your time with. So we know that susceptibility is greater for children who don't have a lot of friends. They want to protect the friendships that they have, and so they're more likely to do what their friends say because they're worried about losing their friends and have difficulty making others. Younger children who hang around with older children are susceptible to influence. Paradoxically, being popular may make you susceptible to influence. This one is a little bit up in the air, but it may be that popular kids in some don't.
事实上，你并不是特别容易受他人影响。这只是和你花时间在一起的人有关。我们知道，对于朋友不多的孩子来说，这种易受影响性更大。他们想保护现有的友谊，所以他们更有可能听从朋友的话，因为他们担心失去朋友，而且很难结交新朋友。和年龄较大的孩子在一起的年幼孩子容易受到影响。矛盾的是，受欢迎可能会让你容易受到影响。这一点还有待商榷，但可能是因为受欢迎的孩子在某些
domains worry about protecting their status. And so they're more likely to be influenced, to be seen doing things that they should be seen doing even if they don't want to do them because otherwise they fear their status will diminish in the eyes of their peers. What about any difference between boys and girls when it comes to peer pressure? We don't have firm evidence on this, but I can tell you this much is for sure. boys spend much more time in groups than girls, whereas girls spend their time, tend to spend their times in friendship diets. And so the influence that boys receive is much more likely to be concerned with fitting
领域担心保护自己的地位。因此，他们更有可能受到影响，去做那些他们应该做的事情，即使他们不想做，因为他们担心如果不这样做，他们在同伴眼中的地位会下降。那么男孩和女孩在同伴压力方面有什么区别吗？我们没有确凿的证据，但我可以告诉你这一点是肯定的：男孩在群体中花费的时间比女孩多得多，而女孩倾向于在两人的友谊中度过时间。因此，男孩所受的影响更有可能与融入
into the group as a whole. And so boys need the approval of a larger group of peers, whereas girls are much more focused on getting along with one or another particular individual. And so we probably are going to see more. individual influence on girls, whereas boys are going to be more apt to be susceptible to forces from the group as a whole. And I'm sure there are some parents that are listening to this wondering what can they do
整个群体有关。所以男孩需要更大群体同伴的认可，而女孩则更专注于与某一个特定的个体相处。因此，我们可能会看到更多针对女孩的个体影响，而男孩则更容易受到整个群体力量的影响。我相信有些听众中的家长想知道他们能做些什么
to help children recognize and deal appropriately with peer pressure? It's a good question. The first thing I think that parents can do is that they can help children recognize that attempts to influence them are everywhere. You can't turn around without somebody attempting to influence you. They want you to eat this or buy that or watch this or listen to that. So one of the first things we can do is we can help children understand that our culture is full of influence attempts. And peers are just another set of forces that are vying for our attention
来帮助孩子识别并妥善处理同伴压力？这是一个好问题。我认为家长能做的第一件事就是帮助孩子认识到，试图影响他们的行为无处不在。你转个身就会有人试图影响你。他们想让你吃这个、买那个、看这个或听那个。所以我们能做的第一件事就是帮助孩子理解我们的文化充满了影响企图。而同伴只是另一股争夺我们注意力
and are vying to shape our behavior. So once children start to see that there are these influences everywhere, that's really the first step in the process. So you recognize when there are influence attempts going on, and you start to label them and recognize them and label them and recognize them, and as children become more adept at recognizing and labeling them, and identifying them, then you can start to talk with them about, you know, is that the kind of influence that you want to be shaped by? Is that something that you want to be susceptible to?
并试图塑造我们行为的力量。所以一旦孩子们开始看到这些影响无处不在，这实际上就是过程的第一步。当你意识到有影响企图发生时，你开始标记它们、识别它们，随着孩子们在识别、标记和鉴定这些影响方面变得更加熟练，那么你就可以开始和他们讨论，你知道，这是你想要被塑造的那种影响吗？这是你想要受其影响的东西吗？
and if not, then we start to talk about how we might resist that influence. But it's much easier to resist influence if you've thought about your strategies beforehand. If it's a teen going to a party and there's going to be somebody drinking there, is that something that you want to resist or not? Certainly you want to tell your team, what are your strategies for if the person who was driving decides to drink? What are your strategies for not getting in the car? What is your strategy for finding a way home? that won't involve driving with somebody who's been drinking.
如果不是，那么我们就开始讨论如何抵制这种影响。但如果你事先考虑过策略，抵制影响会容易得多。如果是一个青少年去参加聚会，那里有人喝酒，这是你想抵制的事情吗？当然，你想告诉你的孩子，如果开车的人决定喝酒，你有什么策略？你有什么策略不坐那辆车？你有什么策略找到回家的路，而不涉及乘坐酒驾者的车？
So recognizing that there's influence out there, and it's not necessarily overt influence. There's going to be a lot of covert, of implicit influence, and that influence is just the same as all the other influence, and children need to be sensitive to that. Parents can serve as a buffer against peer influence. We know that children have good relations with their parents feel that they have less of a need to please their friends.
所以要认识到存在影响，而且不一定是公开的影响。会有很多隐蔽的、隐含的影响，这种影响和其他所有影响一样，孩子们需要对此保持敏感。家长可以作为抵御同伴影响的缓冲器。我们知道，与父母关系良好的孩子觉得他们没有那么大的必要去取悦朋友。
So I'll give you an example of one set of research findings that we have from work that we've done in Sweden. Children who have friends who are really burned out on school who report that they are tired of school, if your friend is a high burnout on school, then you are much more likely to feel less interested in school. School engagement is going to drop over the course of a year. unless you report really strong relations with your parents. And so having a good relationship with your parents is going to buffer you against this adverse peer influence. Some of what you're talking about, a lot of what you're talking about is a negative peer influence, but some of your research has looked at how peer influence can be a positive factor in a child's life.
所以我举一个我们在瑞典所做研究的例子。如果你的朋友对学校感到非常厌倦，报告说他们厌倦了学校，那么你更有可能感到对学校不感兴趣。除非你报告说与父母关系非常好，否则学校参与度会在一年内下降。因此，与父母保持良好的关系将缓冲这种不利的同伴影响。你所谈论的一些内容，很多是负面的同伴影响，但你的一些研究也探讨了同伴影响如何成为孩子生活中的积极因素。
What are some examples of that and what can children and teenagers do to develop these kinds of relationships? Well, if we think about it logically, it can't possibly the case that all peer influence is bad or else children would all inevitably end up as juvenile delinquents because the influence would be negative and more negative and more negative and everyone would be susceptible to it. So there has to be some area of pushback. There has to be some area where peers are good. We know that kids are going to be influenced for better or for worse
这方面有哪些例子？孩子们和青少年可以做些什么来发展这种关系？嗯，如果我们从逻辑上思考，不可能所有的同伴影响都是坏的，否则孩子们最终都会不可避免地成为少年犯，因为影响会变得越来越负面，每个人都会受到影响。所以一定有某种反作用的领域。一定有同伴是好的领域。我们知道孩子们会受到影响，无论好坏，
by whoever is the more influential partner. So if we take two friends and we know that one is particularly influential, let's say the one who has more friend options or the one who is older, or the one who's doing better in school, or the one who's more attractive, whatever, the one who is more influential is going to set the tone for the influence. So if the one who is more influential doesn't like to drink, then we have data that suggests that actually teens desist from alcohol consumption, but the less influential member of the group is going to desist from drink,
都取决于谁是更有影响力的伙伴。所以如果我们有两个朋友，我们知道其中一个特别有影响力，比如说那个有更多朋友选择的人，或者年龄较大的人，或者在学校表现更好的人，或者更有吸引力的人等等，那个更有影响力的人将定下影响的基调。所以如果那个更有影响力的人不喜欢喝酒，那么我们有数据表明，实际上青少年会停止饮酒，而群体中影响力较小的成员也会停止饮酒，
because they want to be more like the more influential one. We see the same thing that levels of delinquency will go down as well. So it all depends on the characteristics of the more influential partner. And the same is true in a group, the group leaders. So the more that the group leaders have a positive agenda, the more that other children are more actually to be influenced by that positive agenda. So if you belong to a group where everybody's physically active, you're going to be physically active. There's a big except for this, except for if you don't want to really, really don't want to do this,
因为他们想变得更像那个更有影响力的人。我们看到犯罪水平也会随之下降。所以这一切都取决于更有影响力的伙伴的特征。在群体中也是如此，群体领导者也是如此。所以群体领导者越有积极的议程，其他孩子就越有可能受到该积极议程的影响。所以如果你属于一个每个人都积极运动的群体，你也会积极运动。这有一个很大的例外，除非你真的、真的不想这样做，
then you're likely to drop out of that group or not be friends with those particular individuals anymore. And you're going to go and select people who are more like you. And under those circumstances when children are deselected from groups or drop out of friendships, then they go and look for kids who are, have more similar levels of perhaps drinking or deviance, and then they may be inclined to be influenced in a different direction. Does peer pressure follow people into adulthood, or is there a point in life when it becomes less of a factor?
那么你很可能会退出那个群体，或者不再与那些特定的人做朋友。你会去选择那些更像你的人。在这种情况下，当孩子们被群体排除或退出友谊时，他们会去寻找那些在饮酒或越轨行为方面水平更相似的孩子，然后他们可能会倾向于受到不同方向的影响。同伴压力会跟随人们进入成年期吗？还是说人生中有一个阶段它会变得不那么重要？
For sure, peer pressure follows people across their whole life course, but you're going to receive it in different ways from different people. So do adults are adults susceptible to peer pressure? I think the answer is, of course. Last night I went to back to school night for my children, and I was very impressed by the whole string of SUVs that arrived, and out of the SUVs got moms with very similar haircuts and very similar length of heels and dads who all looked like
当然，同伴压力会伴随人们的一生，但你会以不同的方式从不同的人那里感受到它。那么成年人容易受到同伴压力吗？我认为答案是肯定的。昨晚我参加了孩子们的返校之夜，我对那一长串到达的 SUV 印象深刻，从 SUV 里下来的是发型非常相似、高跟鞋长度非常相似的妈妈们，以及看起来都像
they had gone shopping at the same place, who differed only in terms of whether or not they were. wore a tie. All had the smartphones in the things. Exactly. So there's no question that we're susceptible to peer influence and that this proceeds across the course of our life. As we get older, we form romantic relationships and we get married, then different peers
在同一个地方购物的爸爸们，他们唯一的区别就是是否系了领带。所有人都拿着智能手机。没错。所以毫无疑问，我们容易受到同伴影响，而且这种情况贯穿我们的一生。随着年龄增长，我们建立恋爱关系并结婚，那么不同的同伴
influence us, but it's still peer influence, nevertheless. Yeah. Well, great. Thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Lowerson. Pleasure with mine. Thank you. For more information, please visit our website at APA.org slash speaking of psychology. Thank you for joining us. I'm Audrey Hamilton with the American Psychological Association's Speaking of Psychology. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
会影响我们，但尽管如此，这仍然是同伴影响。是的。太好了。非常感谢您加入我们，Laursen 博士。这是我的荣幸。谢谢。欲了解更多信息，请访问我们的网站 APA.org/speaking-of-psychology。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会《心理学访谈》的 Audrey Hamilton。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。